foreign
making sure that people are afraid
enough
um you know that they literally stated
um multiple times over the past months
over the past years you know we will
hunt you down wherever you are so that's
a clear message to anyone
um seeking seeking to leave China
already having left China that you're
not safe anywhere
[Music]
our latest investigation 110 overseas
China's transnational policing
um gone wild documents one specific
campaign operated by a couple of
counties within China using illegal
methods to Target approach and persuade
individuals abroad to return to China
against their will illegal methods which
include threatening harassment of their
family members relatives back home but
also the use of individuals linked to
the united front operating in so-called
overseas police stations
everywhere in the world across the five
continents to assist in these illegal
policing operations against Chinese
overseas
the particular campaign to counter
Telecom fraud or at least that is what
they call it has brought back 230 000
individuals between April 2021 and July
of this year according to official
numbers released by the ministry of
public Security in China so obviously
we're talking huge numbers so we started
looking into this specific campaign
carried out by a couple of provinces a
couple of counties in particular and we
came across the fact that they are now
you know using the kind of United Fund
Network that we know exists around the
world but that you know the ministry of
public security the local County public
security bureaus are building on this
existing framework to set up this kind
of overseas well not kind of literally
overseas police service centers that can
be used and have been used so this is
obviously completely illegal this is no
regular International police corporation
which obviously there's very strict
rules these have been set up without any
knowledge of local authorities without
any requests I think it also shows how
one Brazen the CCP is getting and how
little regard they have I would say for
for other governments you know when they
talk about non-interference this is the
kind of non-interference I guess that
that the CCP likes to to boast about
which obviously it's an in violation of
international law it's in violation of
territorial sovereignty
so on these 230 thousands we don't
really have an account of what happened
to to each individual so the persuasion
tactics used when they they use family
members relatives loved ones but even in
some cases you know Community maybe
Community Elders people that are
responsible for a certain
um part of the community they can either
you know keep their kids from going to
to public schools from attending certain
schools they can cut off benefits you
know which may be social benefits health
benefits they may confiscate the
properties of those people they make
confiscate maybe their their bank
accounts or freeze their bank accounts
um you know people may lose their
employment be banned from certain
employment so anything really to
convince them to persuade their family
members or otherwise related person uh
to come back but in some cases it goes a
lot further and they will you know
interrogate people bring people in for
interrogation maybe detain people and
there's also guilt by association
there's accounts of people being
actually prosecuted or arrested for the
charges against their family member or
to presume charges so this is already
happening we we know these techniques
are being used at all levels I think we
were a bit
surprised ourselves to see that even for
these kind of lower level targets we
would say which are Telecom fraud they
are using the same techniques and they
are really building this apparatus
around the world or building on you know
an already existing apparatus and
expanding on it we think we caught this
quite at the beginning the fujawans for
example the one in New York was set up
the first batch only in January of this
year so we're really at the start of it
but we also know that they're building
on an existed network of united front
work organizations so this may escalate
very quickly if not stopped right at the
beginning